so I'm often extolling the virtues of
training with overcoming isometrics and
Static contraction I've talked about how
it can help you improve muscle fiber
recruitment and maximum strength but how
can you use that kind of training at
home well I'm glad you asked
so just to briefly recap for those who
haven't seen my other videos overcoming
isometric is any kind of isometric
wavers in exercise way not moving the
joint for the range of motion and in
this instance you're unable to move it
so you have a yielding isometric which
means for instance holding dumbbells in
this position until your arms give up
and then you have overcoming isometric
where for instance you're trying to push
down a wall in both situations your arms
aren't moving but in the latter the
overcoming isometric you are pushing as
hard as you can and there's no weights
going anywhere and eventually you're
just gonna have to give up it's what
happens when Anna movable force meets an
unstoppable object that's the wrong way
around so this is really good for you
for a number of reasons but the most
interesting one is that it increases
muscle fiber recruitment that means it
increases your brain's ability to tell
them muscle fibers to fire the motor
units and this is because as far as your
brain is concerned it's like trying to
lift something that's your one rep max
it's one way you can train your one rep
max without a spotter and as we'll see
at home because normally if you try to
do your walnut max you'd do it you'd
fail you'd crush yourself but when
you're pushing the movable force you're
still putting in a hundred percent
effort were you still able to put in a
hundred percent effort but some you're
not going to crush yourself and you can
stop and it's controlled you're not
going for the full range of motion and
that's one of the only downsides but
studies show that it can be very useful
nevertheless you can train overcoming
isometric at different points you can
artificially move your limbs and it's
actually one of the training methods
that renowned strongmen like Dennis
Rogers and even Bruce Lee used to
increase their maximum strength without
even necessarily building bigger muscle
they don't need the bigger muscle
because they can recruit more of the
muscle fiber in the muscle they've got
so in a word in a way it makes your
muscles more efficient and it makes your
brain more efficient at using those
muscles so to cut a long story short
it's pretty cool but yeah the problem is
the training this way at home is rather
hard it's very
easy if you're using something like a
resistance machine in a gym where you
can stick the pin in to the highest
weight and just push and no harm no
damage in your house like say you can
push a wall but this is very awkward you
end up probably slipping with your legs
I find it's a bit tough on the knees but
I burst a blood-vessel so how can you
use something similar at home I'm going
to show you one method which is a little
contraption that I have constructed I'll
be right back behold the piece of metal
with a string on it patent pending
SiC it's not really so what I've done
here is very ingeniously take in some
rope and tied it round what was once
part of a pull-up bar for door frame so
now I can stand on the bottom of the
right shoes recommend because it digs
into your feet and then I can put in max
effort into that curl and I'm not strong
enough unfortunately to rip rope in half
so that's not going anywhere
and likewise I've used a figure eight
knot so that's not going anywhere either
how do you pull the title gets so
impossible to slip out of I can do
overhand curls I can do if I stand
further down the rope it shortens it
stand back a little bit so I can do I
propose to work lats theoretically I
could do overhead tricep extensions and
if I put bar on the other side and wants
to lie down which I'm not going to do
right now then you can use it for
training your legs because you can push
down with your legs what's holding you
in place with your arms now some other
cool things you can do with this as well
so for instance I talked earlier about
going through the range of motion
stand back again so I can take my rope
and I can apply max force and I can move
my knees to allow the biceps
she live through the range of motion I
might actually want to make it shorter
so I can do the full range of motion and
I can feel that working the biceps even
though there's no weight involved and
that's also a great way if you don't
happen to have dumbbells you can train
your biceps the same goes for the lat
pulldown la grotte so there yep that's
one example of how you can train
isometric strength at home using this
handy dandy invention and I'll let you
use it
breathe cha just in case you don't know
how to tie a figure of eight knot I'm
going to show you that as well so grab
some length at the end of the rope and
make a loop like so as though you're
going to noose a very small person then
we're going to put our bar through the
leap we're going to take the long end
we're going to wrap it round twice
around the bottom of the loop this is as
though you were if you imagine that loop
to be ahead you're strangling it then
what you're going to do is you're going
to come through the back of the leek at
the end as though you're stabbing it
through it's imaginary I then simply
pull and there you have a figure of
eight knot and you can put as much force
on that as you like and it's not going
anywhere
one of many things that difficult to
train with that method is the pecs and
get around that you can certainly take a
football or something and push it like
so and in fact you don't even need it
football you can just do your most
muscular position and push your arms
together like so and you can again feel
it work in the chest immediately there's
not quite the same method you can use to
train for the range of motion so if you
were going to do this and you want to
strain through the range of motion you
would use a football
and maybe a bunch of other stuff too so
you could start squeezing something
large and pick up something smaller
smaller and again as far as your brain
is concerned you're just trying to crush
100 kilograms makes no difference so
give it a gag that's how you train with
overcoming isometrics at home as how you
build crushing power while sat down in
the comfort of your bedroom or living
room you choose